and now we have our gold medal winner in
the animation category made not far from
here at the California Institute of the
Arts by animator David Wolter the film
eerie is the story of a young shepherd
who must defend his dwindling flock from
a ravenous eagle Oh is there a taller
microphone sorry I can't feel my hands
is that normal I want to thank the
Academy for this incredible honor I want
to thank rich miller and his team the
DGA the wga the ASC the Academy Board of
Governors for a inspirational whirlwind
of a week it's planted seeds that I'm
confident will balloon for the rest of
my creative and professional career I'm
so grateful for that to my fellow
student filmmakers I stand in awe of
your passion and your storytelling
prowess and it's an honor to be counted
among you I want to be clear that I
don't have anything that I didn't
receive any talent I have is a gift from
God and it's been shaped and honed by
the people he's placed in my life and
this film is a great example of that to
the students and the staff at calarts
Bob Kurtz who's here for the vibrant and
robust filmmaking community that they
engender I found all three of my
creative collaborators at that school
Stephen kya van bettin my composer wrote
and recorded over an hour of original
music for the perfect four minutes
Nicole Josephine who provided not only
lighting effects but pivotal animation
feedback that defined performance and
shaped character and my sound designer
Patrick Johnson whose dedication to this
project was so sacrificial that every
time you hear the sound of a sheep's
hoof in my film what you're hearing is
Pat hitting himself in the forehead with
this very rock
no I forgot what I have opposed to say
next it's often said that behind every
successful man is a woman in my case
there are three my mother thank you for
instilling in me an appreciation for
imagination and observation from the
get-go for my sister and her uncanny
ability to detect when I'm full of crap
and she's not afraid to tell me so and
to my beautiful wife Amanda you are my
balance you are my rudder you are the
love of the rest of my natural life
lastly I'm almost done lastly I want to
dedicate this amazing award to my father
who passed away three and a half years
ago everything this film is about all
the core themes perseverance discipline
stewardship are things that he taught me
and I could not have come this far
without his unfailing belief in me thank
you